everybody thank you all for coming
my name is Keith Myers Crum I am a lead
data scientist the citizen oolitic sweer
a data science software and consulting
company and based in Chicago but we have
a DC office too
and I'll be telling about some work I
got to do building some scikit-learn
compatible model stacking estimators all
right so first I'm going to tell you
what I mean by scikit-learn compatible
then I'll tell you out sort of describe
it high level what stack models are then
go into some best practices and sort of
when they work well and when they might
not be appropriate and then finally I'll
show you a simple example of building a
stacked regressor using using our code
let's list some scikit-learn estimators
okay so before I do all that if you want
to get the code play along at home we
would love for everyone here to download
this try it file bug reports ask for you
know future requests etc you can get
from the Python package index pip
install citizen l - extensions if you
want to get the source it's free
open-source software you can clone it
from our github there and and really we
would love you to pull this down try it
out yourself all the stuff in this repo
is compatible with scikit-learn like
there are no weird dependencies it's
just the sort of numpy scifi pandas i
could learn and and it's not just the
stacking code that's in this repo you
can also get implementation the hyper
band algorithm which is really cool as
you're not familiar hyper band is a
bandit based hyper parameter selection
algorithm and so this is scikit-learn
compatible - we have a bunch of cool ETL
tools for pre-processing your data and
then there's also a non-negative linear
regression model which I'll use here
that was a little bit more niche but you
might be interested in it anyways all
right so what do I mean when I say
scikit-learn compatible so if you're not
super familiar with scikit-learn it's
awesome
it has the most wonderful API could do a
whole talk about how much I love
scikit-learn
but we take advantage of the
scikit-learn api which makes it really
easy to swap models in and out in
scikit-learn and also compose estimators
one out of another out of an
and so at a high level the the the the
the sort of top-line bullets about the a
PIR there's this primary abstraction
called an estimator in scikit-learn so
anything with a fit method so fit
usually takes your your covariance or
your covariance and a dependent variable
so in supervised problems you pass in
your dependent variable and unsupervised
it's just your covariance there are two
you know primary types of estimator
there is a transformer so things like
the standard scalar or PCA those are
transformers those have a fit and a
transform method they take your data set
and turn it from one form into another
and then there are predictors and so all
the models that you're familiar with
like linear regression and random
forests and all that those are all
predictors because not only do they have
a fit method but they also have predict
and score methods optionally for
classifiers you might have predict provo
and/or a decision function method but
what's cool about this is that by by
having this the API specified this way
you can kind of swap these estimators in
and out and compose them and then things
like meta estimators like the grid
search CV class or random search TV
which will take in a predictor and a
grid of parameters and then give you the
best model that's a meta estimator and
pipeline which we took some of the set
params get params methods from the
pipeline class and use them in our stack
model pipeline is another really cool
meta estimator where you can chain
together a transformer a transformer a
transformer and then a predictor on the
end and then treat those things as
predictors themselves they have fit
methods they have predict methods and
they handle all the i/o between the
different pieces so cycling learning if
you guys awesome I highly recommend you
read the documents white paper on the
archive by some of the authors the
scikit-learn one final point this is I
pulled a couple quotes estimators are
defined by interface not by inheritance
so that means that as long as you match
this API spec you don't have to inherit
anything from scikit-learn you can play
along like XG boost has a Python wrapper
that has a scikit-learn api to it and
then as long as an estimator files the
api and conventions it can then be used
in lieu of the built in estimator so so
that's awesome so anyone can can write
their own scikit-learn estimator really
easily as long as you implement a fit
method and then if you
predictors should have critical score
all right so onto stack model so what
our stack models these go by many names
like if you search the literature I have
found at least four different names so
there's model and Samba line blending
there's also something called the super
learner
I prefer model stacking or stack models
myself but what what the what a stack
model is is it's a sort of model based
model selection so let's say you have a
classification problem and you want to
try a logistic regression a random
forest and K nearest neighbors what you
might do is cross validate train on your
training set and then you know predict
on your out-of-sample tests folds and
then check the out-of-sample performance
and pick the model with the best
out-of-sample performance
well model stacking does is it takes
those out-of-sample predictions and
rather than picking one best model it
combines all of the models together in a
sort of optimal way so there's this this
higher level model they call it a meta
estimator that takes the outputs of
these base estimators in this example
logistic regression ran for some K
nearest neighbors and combines them in
some optimal way to give you the sort of
you know best of best of all models kind
of approach so nothing in this
description is specific to regression or
classification so this is a sort of you
know meta modeling approach if you want
you can use it in both kinds of problems
so I'm gonna go through a little cartoon
to show you in more detail what's that
models like so at the bottom I have my
data set split into a train and test
fold I have three base estimators you
can have any number any natural number
you probably want more than one but I
have three just for the sake of
illustration and then a meta estimator
at top and so just like when you're
doing model selection you're gonna train
all of your base estimators on the
training the training fold and then
you're going to take all these base
estimators and make predictions on this
test fold on this out-of-sample set
right so for each base estimator there's
some set of y hats that are your
predictions for this the true value y
okay and then you repeat this across you
see B fold so at the end you'll have one
prediction one out of sample prediction
for every you know data point in your
set okay now it now is the part where
this the actual like stacking that comes
in you take these collected Y hats and
you
you squish them together into a set of
features right for each base estimator
there's some added sample predictions
concatenate them into a set of features
and then you train your meta estimator
using those added sample predictions as
your features and the true labels as as
your targets so this is a kind of at a
high level how stacking works so when
should you use these I am NOT a like
kaggle person myself but I've been told
they're quite successful in cattle so
maybe in cattle you should use them but
but the top bullet is basically the same
thing like when you really only care
about accuracy if you really just want
to juice a little bit more accuracy out
of your data set than you might get with
a single model stack models are pretty
good right though they'll they'll sort
of do this sort of optimized model
selection procedure if it turns out one
of your individual based estimators is
just the best your stack model should
probably put all of its weight on that
base estimator and typically will so if
you want to get maximum accuracy stack
models are great sack models also enable
a bit more flexibility right because you
have these different base estimators
they have different assumptions about
how your your you know target values Y
are explained by the data X right K
nearest neighbors makes very different
assumptions then you know linear
regression does but by putting them all
into a stack model you can kind of get
the advantages of all these different
assumptions about about how your your
targets explained by your covariance and
then I also use like if you just wanna
try that you showed everything like if
you like look I tried all these
different models
I even combined them then stack models
are good for that okay they're cases
where they might not be optimal so if
you have like a really huge data set
like all the images on Google you know
you might want to try something a little
bit more flexible I heard deep neural
nets are popular these days you know in
a neural network you can get you know
sort of you can put as many neurons as
you want right there's a there's a sort
of no limit to the flexibility you can
you can build into a neural net so in
cases where you have a really huge data
set you know you may get more accuracy
out of a model like that if you care
about interpretability and in this this
particular bullet refers to interpreting
how your y is explained by your X's you
know if you want to know how your your
dependent variable is explained by your
covariance stack models kind of muddy
the
waters a little bit right because you
have each of these different models that
have different assumptions about how X
explains why so they're not really great
for that kind of which features really
are driving the outcome kind of question
and then finally if you know your data
generating process like if you know what
the right model is a stack model is not
going to give you anything you know
beyond the correct model right or if you
think your data generating process is
simple you probably don't need this much
you know flexibility all right
so those are like the kinds of you know
pros and cons if you decide you want to
go with the stack model that I have a
few tips one you want to pick base
estimators with varied structure like
you don't want to have three linear
regressions as your base estimator
that's not going to do you much good you
want to pick models that have different
relationships between x and y and you
want to pick a meta estimator that can
handle high correlation and so if you
look back on this slide you can see why
right if any of these base estimators
are any good and they should be they're
all gonna be trying to predict the same
thing right each y hat should be trying
to produce a prediction of the same
value therefore your Y hats across your
base estimators are going to be really
highly correlated consequently you want
your meta estimator to be able to deal
with that some models don't handle
correlation as well as others you want
simple meta estimators and this can
allow you to kind of read you know how
much is this model better than that
model so if you use like a linear model
those are those are pretty great meta
estimators
so in particular I have a couple
recommendations for classification l to
penalize logistic regression it's a
simple linear model you can read off the
coefficients but the LT penalty will
help deal with this this problem
correlation across your base estimators
predictions and in a regression case and
non-negative least squares uh leo
breiman of random forests fame wrote a
paper about stack regressions and he
recommends non-negative least squares
these are these these because of that
non negativity constraint it deals with
that correlation issue and the fact that
it's a you know linear regression again
you can read off the parameters and then
the last one for classification problems
you'll want to use continuous outputs so
rather than using like a binary 0 1
label
and feeding that into your meta
estimator what you want is you want to
use the output of the decision function
or predict prabha right because there's
a little bit more information they they
provide some level of confidence about
how you know which class that the model
thinks your observation is in and so in
our in the in the models I'll be showing
you in a second here we into the stack
classifier we built in that it uses
decision function first then predict
prabha then predict that follows the
conventions in the calibrated classifier
cv class in scikit-learn so does this
work
yeah one particular result in the super
learner paper from Wanderlei and pauline
hubbard is that you can asymptotically
expect your stack model to do no worse
than its best base estimator meaning
like your stack model should do as good
as or better than your base estimator
some conditions apply read the paper but
that's good and and anecdotally we found
this to be true so at say this we work a
lot with what we call medium data so
this is like thousands of rows hundreds
of columns you can fit it into memory
but it's not a you know an incredibly
tiny data set we have a lot of surveys
that we make models on so we'll have
survey respondents you know Clinton or
Trump that's the dependent variable and
then a bunch of covariates about these
individuals we found that stack models
you know we have a handful of
classifiers we always run we found that
if we plug them into a stack model and
just use that as a push-button estimator
for these kinds of problems it actually
works really well we get really good a
UCS out of it so there's not a whole lot
of like statistical literature unset'
models it's just not it's just not that
much out there other than the super
learner paper but anecdotally they seem
to work quite well and again Kaggle ok
so how can you make a stack model you
were in luck you came to the right talk
we had a stack regressor class for
regression and a stack classifier class
for classification we basically is on
the side cat learned pipeline class if
you don't know pipeline it is awesome my
colleague Katie Malone wrote a blog post
about doing data science pipeline it's
it's incredibly cool and any
scikit-learn compatible estimator can be
used in the stack model like I said it
doesn't have to be from scikit-learn as
long as it has the fit to predict you're
good to go
and then we also have a
non-negative linear regression class
that I mentioned earlier that's in our
repo that you can use as a regression
meta estimator alright so let's go
through an example this is a like super
simple regression problem and so this is
the data I made what we have is one
feature which is on the x-axis here we
have a hundred data points represented
by the dots they're the true
distribution they're drawn from this
sort of sawtooth looking distribution
right so it's got a slope of one and a
changing intercept every point so this
is just to kind of make a sort of
pathological data set you know that that
would require a little bit more
flexibility than a simple linear
regression okay so 100 data points one
feature one output and so let's let's
let's build the thing so at the top you
see the regular scikit-learn imports
what I'm going to use is I'm gonna use
random forests regressor out of the box
that's ten trees and a linear regression
those are gonna be my two base
estimators and then I used me an
absolute error mean squared error to do
to evaluate the quality of the models
and then here's the imports from our
library so citizen L ext citizen all
extensions that stacking import stack
regressor non-negative important on
negative linear regression and so just
like in the in the pipeline class what
we're going to do is we're gonna pass a
list of named tuples to the constructor
and that's and that's how we create our
stack model so in pipeline you do the
same thing the first entry in the tuple
is a string identifying the predictor
and the second entry in the tuple is the
instantiated predictor okay so here I've
got the random force regressor the
linear regression and then the one thing
you need to know is the last item in
your list is your Mehta estimator okay
so the first two of the base estimators
in the last is the Mehta estimator so
there is a sort of order dependency
there in that the last item has to be
here your med ass so this is so here I
go and make the estimator list plug it
into the stack regressor and then I can
just call fit because it is scikit-learn
compatible all right so let's take a
look so if you want to access the
individual estimators in your stack
model you you can use the estimator list
attribute this just returns to you the
thing that we passed in the constructor
but in this case
models and fit and so if you want to if
you want to look at let's say the linear
regression based estimator you can just
use the you know just just Index this
list of tuples and you can take a look
at the coefficients of that model so in
the case in our case the linear
regression just has one coefficient and
it's point nine three which is pretty
good the real slope is one you know with
that bouncy sawtooth thing on top of it
so this is one way you can access your
estimator another way is we have a named
base estimators property this is a
dictionary where the key is the string
of the tuple and the value is the
estimator itself so here if you use the
name based estimators and ask for the
linear regression you can look at its
coefficients and again it's the same
values above if you want to look at your
Mehta estimator there's a Mehta
estimator property and so here if I do
dot Mehta estimator I get the non
negative linear regression back and we
can look at its coefficients and we see
that the model is kind of a mixture like
2/3 random forest one-thirds linear
regression right so here we have the
coefficients of our of our non negative
linear progression telling you kind of
how much it favors the the random
forests over the generic linear model so
let's do a comparison with the base
estimators so this is this is sort of a
dense slide so let me explain it on the
left hand side we have the linear
regression with the training data and
the random forest alone both of these
are just the base estimators by
themselves with the training data I also
had a test set of a thousand points
generated from the same function that I
used to calculate these out-of-sample ma
ES and MSE s and the upper right corner
you see the full stack model and then in
the bottom right you see the prediction
of the stack model versus the true
distribution so you see a kind of with
just 100 training points it's kind of
capturing that sawtooth looking behavior
if you look at the out-of-sample the
out-of-sample
you know model fit scores you see that
the stack model has an MA e that's a
little you know it's comparable to the
random forest but an MSE that's much
better than both so yes I think it works
and yeah can you grid search of our
hyper parameters yes this is why the
scikit-learn API is awesome you can pass
this pipe there this stack model into a
grid search and just like any other side
killer Nesta meter it'll dispatch
parameters as you would expect so here
again we're making the same estimator
list passing it into the stack regressor
and then passing that into a grid search
cv so here I'm just gonna grid search
over the number of trees and the random
forests and this uses the same
convention as pipelines so if you want a
grid search over something in a pipeline
what you do is you use the you you
identify the parameter by the name of
the estimator in this case it's RF a
double underscore and then the name of
the parameter and so this allows you to
dispatch parameters to arbitrarily
nested things right like we could put a
pipeline in our stack model if we want
that pipeline could have a random forest
in it and then it would say pipe double
underscore random forest double
underscore and estimators but we didn't
do that here okay so we do the grid
search we call fit just like we would
for any grid search we predict on our
test set and then we find that the stack
model with the generics technologist 10
trees does just about as well as the
grid search stack model which in this
case I think had 500 trees anyways it
works it's pretty great and yeah and
that's it so I hope I convinced you that
you can build stack models in a
scikit-learn compatible way it's easy it
works and I would love for all of you to
download this code and use it and break
it and tell us why it's broken so we can
fix it and make it better and like I
said you can pull it you can install
using pip or you can pull it down from
our github repo and so so that is it
thank you all do you have any questions
yes
yeah I guess I do sir
are there scenarios in which you're much
more interested in
that's
yeah so so so I think there's a few
questions so yes there are cases where
we're interested in interpretability and
in those we just probably wouldn't use a
stack model right if you find that your
stack models you know performing
equivalently to a base estimator that's
easier to understand you may as well
just use that but it really it's really
use case dependent if you care about
interpretability though like which
features are sort of driving the
variance you're gonna be better off not
using the stack model does that answer
the question
dates estimators then that distribution
that you have of your prediction but
outlet for predict product would they
would definitely a normal distribution
so having an estimator and being able to
linear regression you speak towards how
you approach that problem it seems like
you might have some
a 20-year meta estimator on top
distribution
yeah so so that's that's a good question
so in one implementation we have we have
a we rather than using the just like a l
to penalize logistic regression we have
a pipeline with a scale like a
standardizing scalar step in front of it
that that's our meta meta estimator I
mean so you can put an arbitrary
scikit-learn object in that meta
estimator to do any transforms you want
so if you're like this is non Gaussian I
want to log transform it or I want to
standardize it you can do that and make
your meta estimator a pipeline rather
than an individual you know LT penalized
logistic regression yeah yes back
yeah
yeah so by default I think we actually
use threefold but you can I didn't show
all of like the what the constructors
arguments are there is a CV keyword
argument in the constructor so you can
pass an arbitrary cross-validation
scheme to allow you to is that what is
that answer you're
so if you have individual based
estimators with dependencies like that
you can specify those dependencies in
that base estimator like if you have a
particular base estimator that needs a
different cross-validation scheme you
can you can if the base estimator
assuming it takes a cross-validation
scheme as an argument you can
instantiate it that way and it will use
that that cross-validation internally to
pick its own parameters does that dress
it okay
sure yes type lines awesome I'm glad you
love pipeline so you're talking here on
the second last line yeah that's we put
in job Lib two parallel eyes training so
so well you can you know specify
whatever job with prams you want to do
multi processing over the training your
base estimators yes and you can specify
him jobs for your base estimators too
and then they'll spawn chopped at their
own
determining which model is best for
interpretation and kind of backtracking
engineering yet so I've been a solo at
one point you know the ratios of saying
that this doesn't read like 66%
explaining it in the freshmen model was
33% his rates Ruth I'm using a score
almost testing with much different
possibilities backwards it's obviously
the trade-off here is that the teletrac
ability if you were to know that a
certain model actually has I don't know
if it so I don't know the answer to that
question I can say that like by reading
off these coefficients that should give
you information about the predictive
power the individual base estimators but
getting down to the level of like does
this base estimator provide a better
interpretation is sounds like spooky
causal inference to me and for sure yeah
I don't I don't know the answer to that
to be honest does that address what
you're getting
yes
I have not used Otto SK learn enough to
give you good answer to that question
that's a good question
yes as any of the estimators yeah yeah
yes you could you could it could be
stacked models all the way down if you
want I don't know if it's a good idea or
not I'm not recommending it I have never
other than other than like the thought
experiment of could you do this and then
like yeah you could I don't have any
idea about I have no there are no
guarantees about how that would behave
what you say you know hopefully yes
that's a good question so so the voting
classifier is if you're not familiar
it's it's like if you have three
classifiers it'll take it takes like the
the this like the class with the most
votes amongst those classifiers right or
it'll do some averages predict profit or
something so you can think of that as
like as a kind of stack model with a
like a simpler meta estimator if you
want I don't have any I can't say
anything about the performance I mean
this is the thing about the stack models
are kind of wild-west right like there's
no like real good statistical guarantees
about their behavior other than that one
super Lerner paper as far as I can tell
I might be wrong I would love to hear
more if anyone knows so I can't tell
anything about performance but I can
just say that like you want to compare
them you can kind of think of the voting
classifier has a stack model with a
simple meta estimator as far as
performance goes your you know your
guess is as good as mine is probably
problem dependent
so that main recently won a stack of
models is essentially to reduce the
inherited - every single algorithm say
well I'm doing random for us no Nets no
whole bunch of other things it's
hopefully giving you a more robust
predictor that's not nom individually
being tinier techniques being used and
so on
yeah yeah I think that's that's one yeah
that's like one I think about it yeah I
think that's one way to say it I think
about it's like you have flexibility
among the different assumptions and by
using these ahead of sample scores
you're trading off bias and variance
like you're getting capturing both of
those things by selecting on
out-of-sample score performance but yeah
I think that's a good point yes
that's a good question I haven't looked
at that myself and I don't have a good
answer for that um my hunch is it's
dependent on the pace estimators and how
they handle them handle points like that
but I actually don't have a good answer
yes you know that's a good question I
think we could accommodate that I'm not
sure but I think we could accommodate
that with the the CVE
keyword argument parameter in the
constructor so if you write a
cross-validation you know a cross
validate or a secular incompatible cross
validator that does what you're
describing you could pass that in to the
constructor of the stack model and it
should use that in its cross-validation
scheme so I think in principle we should
be able to support that I've never tried
it try it out yes yes yes I just made it
up
cool thanks
any other questions yes
I actually don't remember so the way the
way works in the code there's an
abstract based class that we have the
stack regressor and stack classifier
inherit inherit from and those inherit
from base estimator they may I don't
know if they'd heard from the meta
estimator mixin I'm not sure we could
talk afterwards I can I mean I have it
you know obviously on my laptop we could
look at it if you want cool any other
questions I'm not a Bayesian myself I'm
not much of an amazing
so posterior entrance on a stack model
what do the is the inference on the
prediction itself is that what you're I
don't know okay yeah no I know I think
you're right yeah so if you wanted to
get a distribution of your output you'd
have to bootstrap
yes that's right I don't understand the
classic yeah you'd have to resample on
your training set and just look at the
distribution of predictions okay cool
all right thank you guys
[Applause]